let's get into audience questions first
question David we've got the World Cup
going on do you think the World Cup is
an acceptable form of nationalism in
short yes in short yes and there's an
interesting study which questions
whether qualifying for the World Cup
makes countries more nationalistic and
even potentially aggressive towards
other countries in their geopolitics I
am NOT a nationalistic guy right I don't
think that it's anything more than odds
whether you're born in one country or
another I talk so often about how
equality of opportunity varies
drastically based merely on who you
happen to be born to and where you
happen to be born I happen to be born in
Argentina so I'm a fan of the
Argentinian men's national team which
was a very prematurely eliminated from
this year's World Cup and actually now
really not none of the teams I like are
left but putting that aside I recognize
that although my potential was arguably
the same whether my family had stayed in
Argentina or come to the United States
that my opportunity to exercise that
potential went up drastically because I
ended up in the United States there's no
doubt of that and there's sort of this
sliding scale of nationalism and we tend
to see the right much more favorably
seeing the more aggressive engine
jingoistic forms of nationalism I get
into the World Cup stuff and in a sense
you know whether it's an acceptable form
of nationalism kind of depends on your
personal politics I for me it's more fun
and the idea of an allegiance that is
not implicative of going to war or
whatever else but the truth is that
there actually are a lot of politics
wrapped up in the World Cup
I think it's acceptable though I mean
we're not talking about racial
superiority we're not talking about who
was the better military we're just
kicking a ball around after all and I
think if you say that it's not
acceptable then our you know state
championships
you know competitions where one state
goes against another within the US is
that going to be acceptable no that's
going to hold or that's completely
politically incorrect and we
there should be no pride whatsoever in
in your state no Liz I am NOT you know I
think that the left is often unfairly
characterized as lacking all pride and I
hate to even in term patriotism but in a
way sort of accused of lacking
patriotism and I completely reject that
we talked about how when we criticize
our health care system it's not because
we are unpatriotic it's because we are
trying to raise the country up to a
higher standard it's a different form of
patriotism and then when it comes to
soccer you can make the case that in a
sense everything is political that
qualifying for the World Cup does create
a sort of more aggressive geopolitical
outlook but I think that this is not a
high priority and there are much more
concerning types of nationalism than
merely saying hey my family's from
Argentina by the way the US didn't even
make it so I didn't even have a choice
to make between the US and Argentina I'm
gonna root for Argentina I think it's
hot it's effectively harmless and if
somebody disagrees I want to hear from
you